Let's go next to our color from the four four
three area code.
Who is calling today from four four three.
Hello, David?
Yes.
Hi, this is Alex from Baltimore, Maryland.
How are you doing today?
Good.
Thanks for calling in.
Can you hear me okay?
Can hear you fine.
All right, cool.
Just making sure.
I know you get a lot of issues with that,
so I was just curious.
When I talk politics with anybody, I usually
try to figure out when I figure out which
side, if they're left or right, I try to find
an issue where that they might buck their
own trends so to speak.
That was wondering if there's any issue no
matter how insignificant or minor that you
see at least at that.
Do you see kind of from the right wing perspective
or are you all progressive all the time no
matter what?
No, listen, I mean there, there are overlaps
in the sense that for example, um, there are
left libertarian and right libertarian ideas
where there is probably more common ground
ideologically than some people might concede.
Although sometimes it's in the implementation
that there becomes more of a difference.
So I am against any regulation that is not
a necessary regulation to ensure the proper
functioning of society and industry.
So like that sounds libertarian.
The, the problem is I would drastically disagree
with many right libertarians about what the
line is for what's necessary.
Right.
I would want way more regulation than they
would, but at least the concept I, I share
a particularly as like a social libertarian.
I think that on the issue of, let's see, I'm
trying to come up with a better example.
Um, I agree with the idea conceptually that
if taxes go too high, the economy will start
to suffer.
But I would completely disagree with people
on the rightest aware that limits should be,
I think the top marginal tax rate should be
in the low seventies percent for income above,
somewhere in the range of five to $10 million.
So I agree.
If you go too high a, then you hurt the economy.
The people on the right agree with that.
We just have a complete disagreement about
where that line should be said.
So, yeah, I mean, I dunno, I guess it, there,
there are some general areas where I agree
with a principal that might exist on the right
but would vehemently disagree about the implementation
of it.
Gotcha.
That's interesting and nice to hear your take.
And, uh, I got, uh, another, uh, minor complaint
if you have a minute.
Um, I heard on one of your shows that uh,
you think a granny Smith apples are the only
apples that are worthwhile.
I would have to say first of all, how dare
you.
Um, uh, I'm, I'm just kidding.
Um, I would implore you to try a pink lady
and pour a summer R a summer Rambo Apple if
you've never had one of those.
I've never had a summer Rambo pink ladies.
Not bad.
So I should amend my prior statements.
A granny Smith Apple is basically, so I will
disclose.
I don't like Apple pie.
I'm not in the pie space and I particularly
don't like Apple pie.
I don't care about pie period unless it's
like a sweet potato pie.
Okay.
Granny Smith.
Apple is the best Apple for almost all functions.
So if you just want to have an Apple by itself,
a nice tart granny Smith is the best.
If you want to slice it up and put peanut
butter on it, a granny Smith Apple is the
best.
The exception is if you're putting pieces
of Apple in oatmeal and you're cooking it
with the oatmeal and the milk, they're the
granny Smith.
Apple actually isn't the best.
And I would go with some version of a red
Apple in that case.
Yeah, I feel like I said I was just a good
break or your boss.
Yep.
No, but it's a very, very serious issue.
I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.
I hope to hear from you again.
Let's go to our next caller from the two six
two area code.